Says,
Dr. Peterson,
I want to thank you.
We'll just,
this isn't a question for what you do.
I'm a 22 year old girl and your videos are helping me so much with figuring my
life out.
You are alone are helping me be braver everyday.
Well,
I'm really happy about that.
You know,
and I liked your emphasis on bravery,
you know,
because one of the things that we've learned as clinicians say is that when you
help people overcome anxiety,
it isn't that you make them less anxious necessarily.
Although I think you could do that to some degree by having people confront some
of the demons in their past,
but instead of making them less anxious,
you make them braver.
And that's not the same thing,
right?
Because there's lots of reason to be anxious.
The world's full of uncertainty and fear and reasons for fear and reasons for
pain.
But to be braver means to confront those voluntarily.
And that's really a good thing.
When will the next Bible lecturer occur on October 24th.
There'll be three of them before the end of December.
And I want to keep them going into the future.
They,
they've been quite successful I would say.
And um,
I would like to go through the whole book,
although that would probably take me the rest of my life.
But I do really think it's necessary because it is the case that the,
the,
the specific narratives and the metanarrative that are,
that are embedded in the biblical stories and its surrounding literature are at
the fundament of Western culture.
And,
um,
we need to reconnect with that in order to make sure that our,
that our culture stays strong.
And I don't think it's particularly strong right now.
And that's a very bad,
that's a very bad thing for everyone.
It leads to nihilism and despair and,
and an ability to plan for a meaningful future and cynicism and all of those
things.
And that's especially bad for young people because when you're young and your
life is ahead of you,
it's the last,
the last time that you need to be nihilistic and cynical.
It's definitely not good.
So.